[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make way for chase young
great player for the washington football
team you just reacted to that
uh their chase you surprised that
mahomes dad is 50 and
you know brady's 43. yes uh
i just repeated it when you even said it
that's crazy
but tom's what twice as old as you
how strange is that that dear you know
when you faced him you're looking
over the line of scrimmage you're like
that dude is 43.
now it's crazy ever since you know i was
able to play madden
um he was on the game so
it's definitely it's crazy to play
against you know somebody on
that's just been watching your whole
life i love the confidence you said you
wanted tom of course you want tom i mean
you're
you're d your competitor i don't know
why everybody thought oh be careful what
you asked for i'm like no bring it
like if you didn't want tom i would have
questions about you chase
right yes you know you know sometimes
the media would like to you know
get where they can grab me you know just
try to make a big story around the
leading up to a big game so i i
i even being a young player you know i
know how they uh how how that
is um but yeah like you said i'm a
competitor and uh
you know every quarterback i chase uh i
chase down out
every quarterback i play i i want to get
um so
uh today's national recruiting day can
you take us back
or signing day uh can you take us back
to uh your national signing day
uh yeah it was um it was it was that uh
it was at my high school actually
i mean and uh that's just we kind of do
it after school
um and our coach he went from person to
person
uh and just told everybody where we were
going and uh
um you know full rising and just talking
about uh
the season and just uh you know what we
did in high school but uh it was
definitely a crazy time
if you didn't go to ohio state where
were you going
probably no
did you have to tell nick saban you
weren't going to alabama
um no it was a
it was a it was it was a family thing i
cho i chose uh
the school i was going to i chose with
my mom my dad so uh
you know just don't what's best for me
and obviously i made the
made the right choice yeah but you don't
have to tell coach saban that like does
he call and go
hey chase come on what are you doing you
coming with us you rolling with us
nah nah nah that's not even how it's
really set up over there
okay yeah because nick might have been
tough to uh say no to
if he's calling you on the phone i'm
guessing right yeah definitely
definitely definitely now was it urban
meyer who recruited you
coach meyer uh and coach johnson uh
got larry johnson oh okay uh
how do you think urban's going to do in
the nfl knowing his temperament
how he coached in college i think he's
going to um
he's so coach meyer he's a winner one
thing you know he's a winner he hates
losing
um and you know i look back
now um and i used to
i look back now and just realize uh just
how great of a coach he was and
how he pushed me and i didn't i really
didn't even know
um but i feel like you know going to the
league um
he does not want to lose he wants to win
so i know he's going to do everything he
can
to win so uh whatever that has to
whatever that's doing
um i know he's going to take care of us
but i'm i'm definitely excited to uh
to uh you know watch him on on the next
level and i believe we might play them
uh
this coming up season does he know how
to stop you does he know the game plan
here to uh
i've been i've been i've been punishing
his office
[Laughter]
i love it i love it he's chase young of
the washington football team
uh this story about you working out with
arnold schwarzenegger
before the nfl draft like okay give me
how does this come up that your work all
of a sudden the terminator walks in
or you walk in and the terminator's
there uh
it was kind of um i walk in and you know
he was there
and uh we we uh we had worked out and uh
it was really a lot of talking just me
picking his brain just asking questions
about
about everything and uh you know now
we're uh we're we're real good friends
and uh you know while i'm out here uh in
l.a i definitely plan to
sing who could uh lift more
oh you know that ass i mean back then i
don't know he was young he probably
[Laughter]
i'm just curious you know he used to be
you know whatever mr olympia there a few
times so i'm guessing he could throw
some iron around here chase
oh yeah for sure uh were you you were in
the school choir
yes like did you take it seriously
i told you pretty serious i was uh or
did you go there just to meet girls
[Laughter]
okay what should you do better the girls
are actually performing
i mean you know with females i never
really had a super big problem
say that but uh um
nah i definitely went there i was uh i
would leave sing
um sometimes uh and do little solos
um in front of my whole um school no
kidding
we would go to church yeah uh my course
teacher
um was was miss lynn it was my uh
my my fifth grade teacher
um and yeah so i would go and i would
sing up there sometimes by myself during
school
so do you want to sing the national
anthem
i probably could well no do you want to
because i can make some calls
oh yeah i know people
i'm i'm i'm gonna catch you on the
rebound okay all right i'm just saying
if you want to sing the anthem
and you know what maybe you could do it
for a washington nationals game
doesn't even have to be for the football
game you could uh off season
yeah yeah okay i think it'd be pretty
good uh you faced tampa this year
uh if you were going to give some advice
to honey badger
or chris jones what would you say
i mean them them two guys you know uh
i only think i have to give too much
advice to him i mean i i know i know
i know the honeybee i know tyrande
watching film um
i know i know big big chris he gonna do
what he do i'm in the trenches
um he's been doing what he's doing since
he stepped in the lead
um so you know i don't all i say is uh
you know he um tommy get the ball out
quick
uh so definitely for tyrann um
you know whatever you do keep doing it
you're joining us uh on behalf of old
spice uh give us an idea
let me hear your sales pitch here so so
so you know obviously uh it's been a
tough year um
for for everybody um and dinner with uh
i'm just cold here and you know just
everybody's schedules
are just everywhere but uh you know so i
teamed up with a old spice and they're
coming out with a new line
it's called the dynasty um um line and
uh
basically i just put some on it smells
good
um so uh nah it's
this is a real good scent um and it's
that scent that will give you uh
you know just a burst of confidence um
and just have you
ready to smell uh smell rape anything
so but i love it how often do you face a
lineman who needs old spice
probably every game
after
yeah uh hey congrats on the season and
uh
and and good luck in the off season
there and we appreciate your time chase
thank you thanks for having me that's uh
the washington football team second pick
overall and uh they lost to the
buccaneers in that wild card game
uh he didn't get brady he had three
tackles but he didn't get him